Una pausa al menos momentánea entre
contentores políticos junto a quien
podría ser su adversario en 2024 el
gobernador ron de santis el presidente
Joe biden visitó las zonas devastadas
por el huracán dejando de lado sus
diferencias con respecto al 19 el aborto
de los derechos lgbti y el cambio
climático para intentar en conjunto
contrarrestar los efectos de la tragedia
precisamente el presidente
estadounidense señaló al calentamiento
global de los últimos desastres
naturales que han afectado al país
desafortunadamente he estado en muchas
áreas de desastre en los últimos dos
meses los últimos seis meses ya sabes
más incendios en ardidos
los embalses en el oeste están casi a
cero Están pasando muchas cosas y creo
que la única cosa que ha terminado es
una discusión sobre si hay o no cambio
climático y debemos hacer algo al
respecto
en un sobrevuelo en helicóptero dio
cuenta de la magnitud de los daños y
calificó la destrucción de horrorosa
prometió ayudar a los miles de afectados
de Ian que ha dejado más de 100 muertos
y millones de dólares en pérdidas
estamos pensando en ustedes y no nos
vamos a ir no nos iremos hasta que esto
termine se los prometo el gobernador de
santis por su parte aplaudió la labor de
todos los que han ayudado en la tragedia
creo que una de las cosas que están
viendo en esta respuesta es que estamos
eliminando la burocracia estamos
eliminando la burocracia Y eso es así
desde el gobierno local el gobierno
Estatal hasta el presidente Así que
apreciamos el esfuerzo del equipo
a pesar de los esfuerzos aún hay miles
sin electricidad y sin acceso a
alimentos y agua potable el propio
presidente biden reconoció que la
recuperación total del estado tomará
años